so we we saw recently ethan klein of the
h3 podcast and he announced he was
deleting several episodes uh two
episodes he had with jordan peterson
yeah i i feel bad for the guy a lot of
people are mad they're like oh that's a
stupid thing to do and cancel culture
and all that and i'm like dude did you
guys do you follow him and do you know
why this is happening to him by all
means criticize ethan h3 for their
politics that's totally fine and that's
that's the political landscape but
what's happening is someone went on his
youtube channel from a really old video
and they mass reported it and he got a
strike which took his channel offline
for a week he has employees he he needs
to make sure people are paying the bills
now i think his reaction to this was
really really bad what he ends up doing
is saying
i'm gonna go back and delete past
episodes which can probably get me
another strike what people need to
understand about youtube and censorship
and all that is that
i've got
we've got timcast irl where it is a
variety of people but includes me
talking about news and politics i have
youtube.comcastnews
which is me monologuing right and then
youtube.comcast which is me talking
about big stories of the day but they're
so similar i was told by youtube that if
i get one strike on any of these
channels even though they're different
shows i can't do any of the shows that
doesn't make sense because if someone on
one of your shows like a guest does
something that can happen that doesn't
make sense for you to have any kind of
issues i think you guys should revisit
that no that youtube has outright said
we don't care yeah so if the show is is
in any way related when you get a strike
you're done so you can't work for a week
and that means that this is kind of i
mean today we would just go on rumble we
would say okay so this is what i was
saying in a video i talked about this
with ethan klein i said he should have
went on rumble and set up his podcast
there and just said here's why we're
taking these episodes down we'll upload
them to rumble so people can watch them
instead he went the political route and
i disagree with this even klein has long
been comedic edge lord where he's had a
fence of things and that's why they're
going after him but the reason he's
taking down these podcasts in my opinion
with jordan peterson is because
they can go to a three or four year old
video get it flagged because youtube
changed the rules later on
and then his whole company gets shut
down so his response to all this was
i'm taking it all down he has he's been
losing subscribers for whatever reason i
don't know i think this may be related
to it because he did this thing with
hassan [ __ ] the left-wing streamer they
did his collaboration and then he lost a
ton of he gained a bunch of subscribers
and lost a ton of subscribers i wonder
if in his mind he's thinking yo i don't
care about politics i'm just a comedian
guy but they're going to destroy my
business unless i bend the knee his
choice was to fall in line and bend the
knee i think it's a mistake but i
certainly understand his fear of
censorship now this is my speculation i
could be wrong but why would someone go
in and delete old shows there's no
reason to do that he nuked 8 million
views off his channel and in my opinion
it's because the culture war is
escalating the left and probably the
right will go after his old videos i'd
be willing to bet there are people who
are going to start flagging his content
because he's announced he's doing
left-wing content with his son
and you could never appease the mob so
no matter how many times he apologizes
there's still clips of him saying some
absolutely absurd stuff in the name of
free speech that people are going to
bring up and use against them the
strategic move that should have been
done here is build your own platform
build up your own website build up uh
your own subscription model have an
alternative to youtube because all the
writings were on the wall even in 2008 i
remember making videos in 2008 being
like hey youtube it's not going to be a
space that is going to be respecting
free speech and we're going to be seeing
this platform restrict speech more as we
go on and of course this is why i built
my website my email list and if even if
they do take me down fine i have
alternatives i have other ways of even
getting payments there's there's ways
that we have moved away from this big
system and i think youtube recognizes
that that that they're not the the all
and be all right now that there's
alternatives and a lot of people are
exploring those i know you did and it's
been extremely strategic it's been
extremely smart and i wish other people
would just implement those same measures
and not be into this
control grid that we're all in you can't
stop the internet that's what it is
they're trying to the establishment
desperate and the elites the
billionaires many of these ultra-wealthy
individuals they desperately want to be
back in that world where there were five
channels they all marched in lockstep on
all the news stories they all backed up
the the government and the major
corporations they were they could easily
snap their fingers and get us involved
in a war and say iraq like the new york
times did and now it's difficult now
some random dude nabini
screams at a camera for a few years and
people watch the show and how do they
get rid of it well they could outright
ban it they go after steven crowder they
give him a strike even though he's just
citing the cdc that's a really good
example of how they'll lie cheat and
steal but there are limits if they go
too hard then people revolt and they'll
just make new platforms then the
establishment is playing whack-a-mole
game of cat and mouse they'll go after
you know gab and accuse them of all this
other you know nonsense try and get them
banned and then gab builds their own
infrastructure rumble emerges gets
massive institutional investment these
establishment political powers are
losing in my opinion free speech is
winning gun rights are winning and in
that regard i will say i'm fairly
optimistic that authoritarianism will
not be able to prevail because there's
nothing they can do to silence us they
can shut down our twitters but then
getter pops up getter might get crushed
but then people will go to gap it's
never going to stop the internet exists
and they need to learn to deal with it i
think that they're trying to instill a
civil war though in the united states
now they've gone they've given up on
trying to censor people into submission
now they want to see the u.s fight
itself so that corporate governance can
can take hold i kind of disagree i mean
we look at the latest statements made by
the president of the united states he
was begging social media companies and
the corporate media to start censoring
quote misinformation all in name of
keeping everyone safe dr fauci on the
world economic forum also on his zoom
call was saying we need to fight
disinformation for everyone's health
people are understanding what's going on
here the german government is even
proposing on banning telegram i love
telegram i have a lot of fun on telegram
it's one of the platforms that has truly
risen and has allowed people to talk to
each other without any algorithms
without any central controllers without
anyone dictating what you can and cannot
see people are having real honest civil
discussions for the german government
that's a big no no no no we gotta ban
that we can't allow the plebs to talk to
each other how dare they share ideas and
have informed consent about the
decisions that the plutocrats and
billionaires make for them obviously
it's ridiculous to
portray this concept that they're caring
for us by limiting our speech that's a
ridiculous concept and a concept that
has been used historically to oppress
people enslave them and to murder them
that's the true lesson of history that
we're learned here so this is why
they're still trying to censor speech in
my opinion yes less less that it's i
used to think that the goal was to
censor the speech and be done with it
now i'm starting to think the goal is to
take control of the world's governance
with a corporation and then the
censoring the speech is a byproduct of
that or is a step on the way towards
that i would argue that they already did
it in some ways did work took over the
corporate uh overlords have taken over
government and are using them as a tool
as a vehicle for their own hands down
yeah mark zuckerberg knows when you poop
and it's a funny it's a funny way to
explain the concept but the algorithms
the ai of facebook knows when you will
have a bowel movement they know who you
will vote for they can then influence
you facebook ran experiments on people
without their knowledge to see if they
could make them depressed
fact check me on that one yeah i could
be wrong but my understanding was they
flooded people's feeds with negative
information to see if they would get sad
and it worked yeah it was psychological
experiments on unsuspecting facebook
users i've been talking about this for a
number of years now and this is what
they were doing openly admittedly
testing and manipulating people's
emotions with the algorithm seeing how
they could change their emotional state
and if they're doing that with emotions
a couple years ago i think this was over
10 years ago what do you think they're
doing now on such a complex level with
the algorithm only gaining and becoming
more stronger so if they can make you
sad with the algorithm imagine what else
they could make you do if they tweak the
algorithm in different ways
you find a wife they can make you find
your significant other and that's the
one that they want you to find that's
called eugenics wow dude that's creepy
but it's true yeah if you look at
everything the establishment pushes it's
pushing a system that de-incentivizes
the family unit that perverses people's
own sexuality that bastardizes any kind
of semblance of of love and respect and
harmony for the fellow human being if
you look at every aspect of it it's to
destroy families in the future of this
country so going back to the to the
ethan klein thing with jordan peterson a
lot of people on the left and the right
made this about tribal politics and so i
decided to take a look i was like why
would you delete 8 million views off
your youtube channel i was like even if
even if he he doesn't like jordan
peterson there's a lot of videos he
should be deleting because the things he
cited he's got other videos of that
stuff so why is jordan peterson so i
went and looked at his youtube stats and
i looked at his charitable stats for his
podcast and then i saw that there was a
period where he was you know he was
getting hit he was losing subs then i
saw he posted on instagram that people
flagged his old videos and got his
company shut down and he said i've got
10 employees i've got to pay them i owe
rent they shut my company down and i'm
like there it is
they have successfully coerced him into
playing ball with tribal politics
i think it's a mistake i think he should
have stayed true to himself and he would
have been he would have been a hero of
those he he long stood for but to i want
to throw it to you carrie because you
worked for anti-media and there was
something that uh i think was missed by
project veritas and i i could be getting
the story wrong so again you should fac
faction man this one's been it's been
several years but i remember veritas did
this expose on i think it was pinterest
and there was this black list
uh live action was blacklisted it's a
pro-life organization and project
veritas pointed that out when i was
looking at their video when i saw this
report
it lists anti-media and i saw that and i
was like whoa whoa whoa whoa i was like
james and veritas i think they missed it
because they didn't know what it was
they all have everyone has their biases
whether well-intentioned or not and i
think veritas missed that an anti-war
anti-establishment website was also
being censored so so what happened with
all that i actually didn't even know
that pinterest had censored us
i just i think it was pinterest okay
yeah well i remember and i could be
wrong but i think i remember seeing that
google had blacklisted us which makes
sense because we could never get
accepted into google news we'd apply and
apply and we couldn't get in even though
other independent media outlets could
um and this actually reminds me because
we were talking about gaslighting and
the way the media operates and it's
so after the 2016 election the
washington post came out with an article
about all the misinformation and it was
all spread by you know russia russia was
behind it and all these new news outlets
had were spreading this information to
benefit russia and we were put on a list
made by an anonymous group they were
called proper not you can look up this
article search washington post i was on
there too yeah we are on that list as
well and i was like what i'm a russian
asset right i'm polish like how dare you
sorry go ahead but it's crazy though
because i i was i worked for an
organization called the anti-media like
i was clearly i'd already made i'd
already broken ties with the mainstream
media and i came from the left i was a
you know pretty mainstream democrat
voted for obama and so i went through
quite an evolution away from that but
even then seeing my name on that list
from an authority figure the washington
post i was like wait am i in some way
supporting russia what have i done and
i'm like this is driving me insane
because i'm so actively i mean we
wouldn't even quote rt unless it was
like a russian general you know we were
so careful about not being aligned with
state or with governments with
state-sponsored media with really being
accurate and it got in my head so much
and then of course i was angry because i
was like how are you gaslighting me this
hard that i'm questioning my own
integrity and my own practices when i
know them better than any person at
proper not any anonymous person
um but it definitely when the bands
happened it was it happened right after
alex jones so i don't know if you had a
specific question but it was no just
just what happened well i think it's
important to also understand you were
de-platformed in on many different
social media
organizations can you tell us how you
were do platform how you dealt with it
where you are now yeah so it's
interesting because we actually had a
facebook representative working with our
page and that this was back when
facebook was really big it was still one
of the major platforms nobody uses it
anymore i mean nobody i know but i don't
use it um
but we had lost a lot of reach following
the 2016 election we used to have at one
point i had the most viral article in
the world like based on metrics so we
were we were really getting reached and
it wasn't just us it was our partner
partner organizations the free thought
project
it was the mind unleashed and
it was always anti-war police
accountability anti-establishment
anti-cronyism you know we talked about
solutions we talked about you know any
i'm sure things that people care about
and uh then out of nowhere let's see
alex jones was banned august 2018 and we
were banned october 2018 right before
the midterms and we'll never be able to
prove exactly why we got a very generic
notice of like inauthentic no that was
twitter that was wait i can't keep track
of all the places we were banned
anti-media was banned on facebook i
believe they said um
it was something about manipulative
behavior we didn't do any of that we
just posted our articles we had partner
pages but regardless
that was in the morning i think it was a
tuesday a tuesday morning we got that
notice and by the afternoon twitter had
banned us as well and my personal
account was banned i think they're
trying to homogenize the media narrative
yeah and so there were too many voices
the ecosystem was expanding it's
expanding
it was expanding rapidly and even right
now it's really difficult for people to
get started on youtube because they want
to make sure there's a very narrow path
you can walk right only if you have an
acceptable voice
and the corporate ties so if you're tied
into major major special interests in
corporations you're going to get pushed
in the algorithm you're a joe schmo you
have absolutely no chances of making it
what they're doing right now
is they've isolated they've they've
secretly in my opinion based on the data
quarantined channels like this one and
many others now i think we were
quarantined for some time but we were we
had that lifted for some reason i think
you know we we are on the edge of what
they like they find tolerable and i've
often explained it as a pressure release
valve if they ban too many people at
once everyone just jumps ship and goes
somewhere else but if they want to
control people's thoughts what they'll
do is they'll ban some and then make
sure channels like this one remain so
that people won't leave the platform and
they can keep feeding them a narrative
so i i've talked about this in terms of
effective censorship versus what a lot
of these companies have been doing
saying that if you if you give people
clear rules and understanding they'll
follow it but if you ban them out right
you make them jump ship to other
platforms where they maintain and push
and double down
i think that's what they're doing i
think the reason so we were blacklisted
for a while this channel you couldn't
google search it you type in the name
and you get facebook instead of youtube
you type in youtube and try nothing none
of it would come up
some that changed i think at some point
last year and it was funny we mentioned
on the show then the next day everyone's
like hey you're not blacklisted anymore
and i'm like interesting the first night
i mentioned dmt
all of a sudden they were like not true
by the way
that's what i like to think the machine
l set us free i
to put it simply i think
the reason anti-media gets banned the
reason why alex jones gets banned the
reason why they're going after crowder
is because they have the the the the
road they've paved and if you walk off
of it you're out what gets me is that
you got banned on facebook and then
later in that same day on twitter that
makes me think that it wasn't someone at
facebook called someone at twitter and
was like hey that it was somebody above
both organizations was like it's time
that's what it makes it seem like but
that's and that's the thing is
conspiracy i can't claim anything with
certainty and i'm not going to because i
don't know but they had started working
with the atlantic council their i think
it's called the digital forensics
research lab and they were supposed to
be analyzing social media and helping
platforms like facebook and twitter weed
out anything that could threaten
democracy and hurt the integrity of
elections and that council was connected
with henry kissinger who of course is
also a very big fan favorite of we are
change when we were conducting
interviews of him and obviously that
didn't play a role in us getting hit on
the facebook and and youtube and twitter
and all that other stuff last year by
the way uh the facebook page that i run
on on we are change got a strike because
we posted a screenshot of the cdc
website talking about breakthrough cases
louder crowder got hit for mentioning
cdc statistics so it's not even just
walking the tight rope even if you
regurgitate the narrative back at them
they still have the indecency to try to
destroy your livelihood take away
everything you worked so hard for all in
a moment's notice because you're not
helping the multinational corporations
you're not helping the special interest
you're not helping the billionaire's
class you're not helping henry kissinger
bill gates and all these other people
push their agenda onto everyone else so
it's becoming sick and twisted to such a
degree that you can't even talk about
the official story anymore well it's
it's it's so telling too because the
things we care about the things that we
covered war empire police brutality mass
surveillance these are things that to
many people on the left who are
principled it's this is not taboo to
discuss we're not talking about things
that are out we weren't you know we
weren't
we weren't noticeably right-wing in any
way so all i'm left to believe is that
whoever made these decisions didn't like
the lens we were framing it in it wasn't
that we were anti-war it wasn't that we
were against the empire it was that we
were framing it through an anarchist
lens that was completely outside the
realm of political solutions like voting
or something that people would consider
acceptable we were advocating
an overhaul of the entire thing and i'm
left to i mean again i can't say with
any kind of certainty but it seems like
that was the issue i want to i want to
address
one of the super chats before we move on
to the next segment normally we just
save it to the end but people have
pointed out that ethan klein has
very very offensive shows where he makes
you know racial slurs and he says things
like that and homophobic slurs oh yeah
yes yes yes i i know and i don't think
that changes my point i think my point
is him getting rid of the jordan
peterson episode is because he's scared
of the left going after him and getting
him banned so he's siding with them in
hopes that it protects him and they
won't go after him it's the metaphor
again is like if a doctor is like hey
that you have an infection we're cutting
it off and you're like ah and then you
start looking around at your body you're
like that might be an infection that
looks like an infection i'm cutting it
off he cuts that off that might be an
infection then everywhere he looks he
starts to see potential infection so
he's cutting his own your videos off
you're missing what i just said
he has a video on his channel someone
mentioned where he says racial slurs
over and over and over again he hasn't
deleted it it's not an issue of him
saying i've done something wrong it's an
issue of him saying and this proves my
point it's not about him agreeing with
the left it's not about him actually
disagreeing with jordan peterson it's
about him saying this is what will get
me banned if leftists flag my videos
they're not gonna go after his idubbbz
thing
they don't care about idubbbz that's
that's what they're mentioning idubbbz
the interview they're going to go after
jordan peterson which will get him in
trouble so i i think he's he whether
whether he wants to acknowledge it or
not i think this plays a big role in his
political shift he's scared of getting
canceled he's siding with them in hopes
they don't flag his content but you're
saying he has homophobic content he's
not deleting so i i i wouldn't call it
homophobic i would say that he's
intentionally being offensive as
possible by saying a racial and
homophobic slur together over and over
again and yeah
the first thing he would want to delete
if he's concerned about people on the
left coming after him not not if he
sides with them you see
are they going to go after a youtube
a youtuber
no are they going to go after jordan
peterson yes so he starts agreeing with
them he starts defending them he starts
saying this seems safe and acceptable
they're not going to flag my content but
they would flag jordan peterson i'm not
saying he's the smartest guy in the
world i'm not saying he's perfect and
there's another comment where they're
saying i'm just defending him i'm like
dude first first and foremost i don't
agree with his politics that's fine
criticize the guy all day and night i'm
pointing out there are people like this
is a guy who was just an edgy comedian
what does he know about politics he's
even said he doesn't know and now he's
getting inundated with attacks so he
decides
to stay safe to survive at all costs
like um
who mentioned this uh the other was the
other day they mentioned the gulag
archipelago yeah it's james james yeah
james right right he was mentioning
survival at all costs that's what this
is and it's strategic
if he really cared about what the left
was saying if he really believed it he
would have deleted that episode he
didn't which says to me it is his fear
of the culture war i got more that he
wanted to do a high profile takedown of
jordan peterson for views that was my
but he didn't make a video about it he
just tweeted i mean i'm sure he talked
about it on his new channel but i don't
think he's even done a full page right
there's more to it yeah yeah but also
everyone everyone's talking about him
now which also achieved the goal of
getting attention for this which could
have been something that he was seeking
potentially and if he removed a bunch of
wants
it wouldn't be now he gets to do he can
remove a video every two weeks and stay
in the limelight nice job ethan come on
dude
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time